(gentle piano music)
- Man that was so much
fun, what a good game.
- Oh, so good, perfect.
- So well played.
- Also I think I've been
drunk since breakfast though.
(murmurs in agreement)
- Hey kid, how you holdin' up?
- Pff, great.
- Oh, those nachos.
- Oh yeah.
- Oh my God, those nachos, they were like
the perfect level of green peppers, man.
- Yeah, but they were like 80 dollars,
that's okay though.
- That's a ball park.
- That's a ball park, no big thing.
- Oh this is me.
Well that's me, up there.
- Wow.
- Wow, all the way up top?
- Yeah, good leg workout.
- Do you have an elevator or what?
- Uh, no.
No elevator.
- All right.
- It's cool though, you know, I'm chill.
- Okay.
- Yeah.
- Good, stoked.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah I'm good.
So, phew, yeah.
- Are you, you good?
- You you...
- Yeah, yeah.
- You sure?
- Oh yeah, I just think
about how much fun today was.
- Oh, yeah it was.
- You guys are great.
You're chill, I feel
like we all meshed well,
we're all s-so chill toghether.
- You're gonna be okay, right?
You okay?
- All right, we'll see you next week.
- Yeah, see you Monday.
- Man, I want more of those poppers.
Yeah, probably.
(farting)